how about them apples megan fox and
kourtney kardashian pose for a seriously
steamy photo shoot it's like insane
the 42 year old reality star and the 35
year old actress cozied up together for
court's sister kim kardashian's
company's latest shapewear campaign
modeling several bras and panty sets i'm
really freaking out the handsy shots hit
social media on wednesday one of the
sexy snaps features court doting on
megan feeding her from a plate of
cherries it's the queen or no one while
in a few others they're in an embrace
isn't that my job megan shared a few
pics of the pair posing topless to her
instagram and captioned them in part
court forever isn't long enough
people love it court and megan have been
spending lots of time together as of
late and it may be because their
boyfriends travis barker and machine gun
kelly are bffs and frequent
collaborators they want it down
[Music]
earlier this month fans went wild when
the ladies introduced their bose
performance at the mtv vmas calling them
their future baby daddies whatever daddy
says and the internet's gone abuzz again
over these photos courtney's sister
chloe reposted some of them to her
instagram story writing in separate
slides
i am
not
okay
and i was so distracted by their hotness
and kim is getting lots of love for her
choice in models megan fox is so hot
that flashback is from 2009 when kim
told et she's a big megan fan while
attending the premiere of the actresses
movie transformers revenge of the fallen
with her then boyfriend reggie bush
she's like my girl crush and i don't
have girl crushes safe to say after
seeing these pics we're all crushing and
suddenly have a craving for fruit
[Music]